Chris if you were a free agent now what
would be the number one thing that you
would be interested in well with all
money kind of being equal if I was yeah
Wow stability drama-free great chemistry
and so all that being said I don't know
a physician but about a year and a half
ago I said that I thought it's been
before I got to the Toronto Raptors I
thought he was going to go to the
Clippers and you know me out here I
would talk this morning about how aliens
in the picture I just I just can't see
that I think for Kauai is still a
two-team race and you know Dan everybody
sleeps everybody sleeps on the logo
everybody sleeps I mean you think about
a Jerry West he started what's going on
and Golden State he started what was
going on in LA all those great years
with Shaq and Kobe and everybody thought
he was stupid for trained Kobe for
bloody and I just talked with them I
love them as a fan as a basketball
player and people sleep on his
recruiting I'm not saying he's gonna get
Kawhi but just don't don't sleep on the
man that is the logo being in the office
of the Clippers haven't done this many
times before I still look at Kauai and I
don't know him I don't know who knows
him but I I guess I'm just gonna look at
this from a logical standpoint and that
is if you want to win you still get paid
you want to win I would think Toronto
would be the destination of maybe a one
plus one deal for him you're you know
the East is wounded Boston's wounded
Milwaukee might be wounded they may lose
some players the 76ers perhaps gonna
lose some players and Toronto is going
to be still Toronto and there's value in
that if and if you want to be drama-free
you got a chance to go back to the
finals and that would be the place that
I would go what do you make of that I
think it makes a lot of sense but I
don't think we take into effect what a
perfect storm it was for them to win
this year so let's say that MB would
have hit that shot and it's in four
bounces in game seven we think he'd be
out of there
right because we would say well that was
the full potential and full potential of
them and don't get me wrong I love Van
Vliet but I love Van bleed I love siakam
I think she Akram is the best piece they
have besides Kauai I love Lowry but that
team isn't sustainable to win like that
again the first team ever we got to give
him their props first team ever to win
without the first-round draft pick or a
lottery pick whatever it was yeah that's
not gonna happen again
Gasol is older he barely made it through
this series not he won the championship
and he did his thing so I don't want to
just throw him on the bus I'm not saying
that but I'm just saying he's a year
older they'll probably trade I'm 26
million on the cap so I don't um I hear
what you're saying I could see one more
year but I do not think that's the place
for stability of winning you know this
this to me was their one chance and even
though even though the stat sheets even
though the rosters don't say that that's
just the feeling I get about it Toronto
you're right drama-free good to go but I
mean you I forgot what players said it
the other day maybe it was Lou Williams
he says you love it you love the city
but you're looking at six months you
don't want to be there and that's with
you know if you really want to get into
the culture of basketball you don't want
to live there I'm just going to tell you
from friends being there for being in
Detroit from driving up all the time
four or five hours away you don't want
to be there it's you just don't it's the
farthest travel you have to go through
customs every game is you know for them
in Memphis those are the worst traveling
schedules you can have out of any team
Memphis should be in the East Coast they
travel the west coast schedule and
Toronto it just gets hectic and the cold
weather is bruising so guys do take all
that into account when the money the
equal only money dealer did you play for
a team that you didn't like because of
where you were playing Sacramento in the
beginning yes and then those people and
those fans and that community showed me
that if you just take a second and
breathe here you'll realize we got San
Francisco Tahoe Vegas all around the
people here are wonderful you have a
great organization but I was kicking and
screaming the whole way and as you can
see though I wanted to stay they have to
have to kick me out there so he
definitely can turn around I mean I love
that place forever it's my second home
but I just you know it's one narrative
about how great Toronto is and it is we
the north they're the best fans man it
was awesome being up there during the
finals but it's not it's not America
let's just get it straight there's no
sports center I can't find you that
easily over there it's harder to find
your TV shows just going out while
you're eating if you're a sports fan and
we're talking about convenience we're
not talking about you know the end of
the world oh type of things so if we're
just talking about convenience it's one
of the most inconvenient places to live
if you're used to what we have here in
the states it is used to our culture if
you're Kevin Durant what is going to be
the reason why you stay the reason why
you go so this year we have most free
agents that we that we've had and the
most free agents that have had
championship pedigree so in other years
it was KJ trying to go get a
championship myself or this guy trying
to run over here and get one well this
year we have you know guys like Kyrie
and Durant that have championship
Thompson so with them I think it can be
about a narrative it does
Thompson feel underappreciated I don't
know does Durant want to show everyone
now that y'all talked about me because I
left it 3-1 I went to go jump on the
bandwagon of a team that that I was
beaten and I didn't stand another year
and beat them with another all-star so
now maybe I'll go to New York and play
by myself and show you guys that I can
do it you know I really wouldn't be put
it this way I think everybody not not I
think a lot of people are ignoring the
interview that Andre Iguodala did about
Golden State while selling his book
which is a great book six men by Andre
Iguodala but he said last year that they
lied and said he had a bone bruise he
said last year he had teammates coming
to him asking him why wasn't he planning
he said he had a fracture he's saying
that for a reason let me let me just say
this guys on the team are always closer
than guys on the team with the
organization so if you ever want to know
how the real team feels look how they
talk about a player or state quietly so
what I took from that conversation of
Andre Iguodala was him saying basically
hey I wouldn't be mad if Katie left
either because I've gone through it
before or why would he reinforce that
story and
enforce that narrative you know and so I
could see Kady
I I could see Katie and Kauai and the
Clippers or I could see Kady in New York
somewhere we're talking to Chris Webber
NBA on TNT analyst who who do you think
if you could say to LeBron this guy is
the right fit for you
mm-hmm who does LeBron want to bring in
that's a great question I would say
who's the best shooter available I think
that's the only person that you go guess
I'm not all giving wrong if Kawhi and
I've been hearing rumors I was thinking
about the Lakers which I seriously doubt
then you got to get that three-headed
monster because if LeBron gets Hertz
next year you're done and there's a
chance he gets hurt everybody was no
surprise last year there is like if that
was over-under I would bet on him
getting hurt not because I want him to
be just because age and father time and
we've heard all of that so their
question is do we need to go get another
max player that can take over if one of
these guys get hurt or do we need to go
get some pieces are la a Toronto I would
I would caution him and say listen go
get shooters shooters are what going to
help you at the end of the day ad is
going to take up space you're gonna be
in the pick-and-roll you're going to be
doing different things you guys need to
be able to attract to and kick it out to
one and so even with the game of Coulomb
I mean I really don't know I don't think
Butler's the answer you know I do think
a guy like Brogdon would be very good
but he doesn't he doesn't add that style
far but he's a 4050 no I like everything
you know I love his game and he's so
calm I think that he would be great man
within that circus of la demeanor you
know so I think they should go with you
know guys like that by Donald itch you
know not necessarily Kimber but I think
they should go with not their superstar
guys but those guys are really more than
glue guys but guys that hold the team
together and can take you on a
consistent night but more importantly
can be stable in that locker room when
you lose two games in a row in the world
says these are the worst trades ever and
so that's what I would caution shooting
and guys with great demeanor in a locker
I said something in the first hour that
my guys thought was questionable and
certainly headline
if I'm the Lakers I I would take klay
Thompson over Kawhi Leonard if I if both
guys are available and I can only pick
one of what I think will work for the
Lakers
I'd pick klay Thompson go ahead and yell
at me if you'd like the only so Kawada
me is a better player yes then clay yeah
but that makes a lot of sense what you
just said okay because will you be able
to take off so let's just say the tiger
game is down at the end and LeBron has
the ball in his hands well we've seen
kowai kowai is not an off the ball
player he's on the ball player now
popping them has him handling the ball
which led to them nursing them
continuing to let him handle the ball so
at the end if you have two ball handlers
out like Kyrie and LeBron it tougher to
get that guy a wild open shot whereas if
you have a pick and roll with LeBron and
AD and you have klay Thompson out there
who doesn't need dribbles who
automatically has ball movement for your
team so LeBrons older he's not running
up and down as fast as we've seen him
but he's you know take these to be more
cautious and taking the time ad we know
what he's going to do if you have a guy
that moves in the offense there screams
that comes off screens that can shoot
the way he does I don't think you're
crazy Dan the only thing I would worry
about is is his knee healthy but clay is
one of the toughest guys in this league
and we sleep on him as a two-way
defender I know they have dream on and I
know they have Durant but Knightly
Knightly Thompson checked the best
player on the team because it usually
was a guard or a smaller guy and he was
on that guy so no that's not crazy at
all not crazy at all all right I'm gonna
leave you with this yesterday I go I
don't remember a time when we had so
many names that begin with the letter K
and then I thought if I put the team of
Kay's together in the history of the NBA
I think I could beat anybody and then I
started to look at this so let me run
down my team I got Kevin Durant
I got Kareem I got Karl Malone Kobe
Bryant Kevin Garnett and Kyrie Irving
that's Mike that's my team now you're
probably saying well what about Michael
and magic that's great I thought about
that yeah Michael
you know most Moses yeah Manu ginóbili
Mel Daniels Marcus Johnson so alright
tapers off a little bit there let me see
let me see who I have on your team Chris
Paul Charles Barkley
Clyde Drexler you and Chris Bosh okay
let me see what else I have here so I
got oh here's one
LeBron Larry LaMarcus Aldridge Larry
Nance Lou Williams now it's kind of
table but I do like LeBron Lou and Larry
Bird you got some scores right there
yeah you know what
this is something's gonna be on my mind
all day and I'm gonna think about it I
would come up with a team I like what
you did there but cuz you can still go
last names to write so I can go Barclays
boss or Barclays bird or does it have to
be firm no because it's about the cage
this year it's all about the case okay
yeah yeah I can't think of anything when
you go collide Kareem and Kobe in coral
anger gee I wish bang I wish I could
just throw I wish I could just pour some
water on this theory real quick but I
can't is notice one be the best here's
James James Harden Julius Erving Jerry
West John Stockton all right that's it
that's good that's pretty good Jerry now
your first name is mace yeah that's
right let me see what else I got Tim
Duncan Tracy McGrady Tim Hardaway Terry
Cummings Tony Parker Shaq Steph Curry
Steve Nash Shawn Kemp Spencer Haywood
okay but put Toni Kukoc on that t2
because I think it's some time change I
don't know if they can get their time
same with Toni Kukoc here's one here's
one Russell Russell Westbrook Rick berry
Robert Parrish Ray Allen Reggie Miller
rod Strickland I really like that's
pretty good
that's good you can move rush to the to
lavage strickland hands in a barn that
way you know yeah I like that I still
think the Kay's got Kay's got him hey
it's great to talk to you enjoy the
offseason we always appreciate your time
Chris and thanks for joining us
appreciate God's on Chris Weber for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]